pretty interesting Arbitrage here find
this very fascinating overstock.com buys
Bed Bath and Beyond at a bankruptcy to
use the brand name to Rebrand
overstock.com I like this I love
arbitrages I love when people are
thinking a little bit differently you
don't see this all the time and for a
lot of internet companies or small
entrepreneurs here for a lot of you you
may have really good businesses in
really good sectors we're an iconic
company in your sector is actually out
of business or on the way out and buying
it just for the ARB of the name given
the size and scale you might be at
overstock's a big company some of the
people watching here are gonna be too
small to do this but for the ones that
are a little further along this might
become a more common move as some of the
iconic Brands uh that we know in
different categories start to face big
challenges by not being contemporary
marketers not winning on the internet
not winning on social
I thought this was clever I thought it
was worth sharing hope it brings some
value think about little moves like this
like new account names and things like
that for you